太った？
第一回　右折と左折を繰り返すとどこにたどり着くのか？　ドライブ～！！
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーとたな
車とは、直進、右折、左折３つの、この運転中に動く方向があるんですけどもー、
右折と左折を繰り返すと……どこかにつくんじゃね？っていう
そりゃどこかには着くでしょう。
wwwwwすみませんね
どこかにつくんじゃねって気はしてるんでー、
今日はそれがどこなのかをちょっと検証していきたいと思います。
全くよめないっすね。
もうとりあえず、右か、左か、曲がるべきところがあったら絶対曲がっていくスタイルでー、
右折と左折を繰り返した末にー、どこにたどりつくのかっていうのを、検証していきたいと思います。
では、早速やっていきましょう！
どこら辺がいいかなー？
まぶしい…いやほんとねぇ…
ブレーキと連動して…ほら音が。ホントだ。
(はじめのあくび)
スタート！えっ？もうスタートです
まずは右折だね。右折行きまーす！はい。
右折～。
で、このまままっすぐ左に曲がりたいと思って、
行けるね～。
行きましょう。
えっこのへ…
はい。細いねー基本的に道。そうですねー。
うるさい！
上がってきます。んあ～
ほんとカーナビほんと…
ヤベ、ヤベ、ヤベ、暴走族、暴走族。暴走族、暴走族。ほんまや。
これ左行けますね。左マーマン？
ねえ、ちょっとまた大きい道に出た。
これは右に行くと逆走なので逮捕ですね。
これもう…仕方ないよね。じゃあ右折入りまーす。
細い道だー、すぐ細くなる。人がー。一通多っ！
結局俺たちは流されるままってことか。
ここか。
でも着実に進んではいるよ。そうですね。
曲がりまーす。
右行きまーす！はい。
あー、まぶしー…。
ああいうお母さんいいよね…。ああいうお母さんいい…。
お母さんになりt…うわあ
お母さんになりたいの？
いやマジミスドとか行きてえところなんだよなー。ほんとに、美味しく………
美味しく、で？wwwww
ここか！はい。
こっちか！待ってそっちの大通りがよかったんだけど～
うわ、こーゆーとこ行っちゃうー。
なんかまだ都会感があるから～。確かに。まだワンチャン。
ねえ、待って、待って、待って。やばい、やばい、やばい、やばいやばいやばいやばいやばい。
実際、あ、あ、でもギリた…これ右…無理だよね。直進だもんね。このまま直進
あ、でもギリギリほら看板が！左だったら積んでた。もー、ほんと。
これ、右まえる。はい。危な！待ってこれ俺の車が限界を…
超えていく。
あー、あぶねーあぶねー。あぶねー。
オッケー、オッケー、オッケー
お～いいんじゃない
かぜがついたね。うん。
マジどこに行くんだろう？
ただち、ほんとゴメン。さいっ、先に謝っとく。
えー、お願い、お願い、お願い。
曲がっていくから…うわっ、待って、待って、待って、すぐ右だよ？(汗)うわ…。
うわっ、これちょっと、大丈夫かなー。
そして…ギリいける、ギリいける。ギリさえ？ギリさえ。
これ左行けます。オッケー、あぶねー。
うわーーーーーーっっっっっ！！！！とととと、あぶねーーーーっっっ！！！
で、次が？
右、次が右。
あ、行ける、行ける。
っくっさーす！うそじゃーん！(泣)
でも、左行ける。これもう左行けるんですよ。
うわ、待って、こういう道が一番ね、人には気をつけましょうね、細い道は。
んで曲がってゆーく。
んで次は右だもんね。次は右です。
え、俺もうここわかんないよ。もう、、
え、もう知らない土地ですか
もう俺、分からない。ここまでくると。
タースケテ。
次、右だ。(眠)
お、ようやく
うわー、ちょっとそろそろ町はずれてきてるよ。
左曲がってゆく！
オッケイ。
あー俺ねここは分かる。でも。へー。ちょっと取り戻した。
いや、分かんねえわ！
PokémonＧＯとかでここら辺来てたりしないんすか？
いや…あんまりね。基本海のほうとか行っちゃうから。
あ、でもでかい道には出ました！
ホントだ。
え、待ってここ左いけるやん！
うわーーーー。
でかい道行きたかったよー…
曲がっていきまーす(悲)
うわっ、これやべぇ！(はじめの鼻笑い)ごはんどころじゃねぇ（笑）
こっち行けるよね多分。
完全に行けるよね。
行ける。
無理やり曲がっていきまーす。はい。
さあ！
またちょっと良い道に出たがー？
真夏のところで後ろが来るのは分らんからな…
うわーここ、右かー！(泣)
わ、すげえ曲がりたくねえな。
大きい道には一瞬しかいれない！
ね、ほんとね。
曲がっていきます。はーい。
いまー公園でいるさー住宅街は避けたいところだよね。
えー待って、この、これもーすごいよー。
おばあちゃんが道路の真ん中チャリで走るくらいだから。
左曲がっていきまーす。
信号は右ー。
おおー、でもおおー。
左曲がっていきまーす
あ、待って、久しぶりになんか逆方向に行ってるよ。コレ。
太陽がバックに来た。
ええここで？(悲)
ここかー(泣)
おんにちるが…待ってここやばいよー！(苦笑)
wwwwwそろそろやばいよ？
左曲がっていきます！
狭い！…オッケー。
これか！
うあー…
やばい、もう完全に…。
これ、行き止まりとかにたどり着いたらゲームセット？ゲームセットすね。
これ道？
道…だね。
お、待ってこれもうやばくね？
でもまだかろうじで右には行けるー。
行けないですよ。あれ、家ですよ。
www家だねぇ。壁。
とぅてってってってってってってって
てーててらてーてー
てれれれーててれてーれ
てーてーれれてれれてーれーれー
ってってってってててててん
終わっちゃった。終わっちゃったねぇ。
というわけで…右折と左折を繰り返してたら…
壁。
いやーもうちょっと行ってると思ったんだけどなー
俺もう、帰れないと思いましたもん。今日。ね。
なんかワンチャン新潟とかさー山形とかまで行くと思った。
山形ってwww東北ですよ。
意外となんかねぇこういくからどっかに絶対行くんだろうなって思ったら、
まあこれがまた一つの検証結果でした。
また機会があれば右折と左折を繰り返してみようと思います。
ｗｗｗばいばい